mom is my vagina supposed to do that mom
mom mom don't make a dentist appointment
how do I saw a chicken can you do it for
me what is my social security number how
do you soften butter and I forgot slicks
password can I have your HBO Go password
mom how many stamps do I put on
something Windex on wood ray what would
actually happen if I washed whites and
colors together if your dad's birthday
how do you cook rice
do I have credit do you have credit can
I have some of your credit right a
tetanus shot how many minutes do you
boil an egg for are you supposed to ride
your bike with or against traffic when
is mascara expire how long is shaking
good for well how long does cinnamon
stick it for no for years how do I wash
something that says dryclean only no I
did not get red wine on my shirt again
how do i unsign up for a credit card I
have any allergies I don't know about
what about shellfish I don't fish
without shells may use the moment
airline miles
what is our family medical history I saw
the chicken in the microwave and then I
ate it
am I gonna die hey mom I had a question
why did I ever want to leave home god I
miss you like you used to annoy me when
I was a teenager but like I really miss
you know I can hear you I mean I'm going
through a tunnel